good morning believe nation today's
messages attitude is the difference
maker over to you John Maxwell have you
ever heard a motivational speaker tell
you that attitude is everything I'll bet
you have I've heard many say that in
fact they'll say something like if you
can believe it you can achieve it and
that never quite rang true with me so I
began to press the issue and I have come
the conclusion that attitude isn't
everything
now I'm not disclaiming or in any way
being disparaging about attitude because
I think attitude is very important but
if anybody comes up to you tells you
that attitude is everything I don't buy
into that that's not true for example
attitude can't replace in confidence if
you're in confident you can be very
happy but you can still be very
unsuccessful now here's what I do know
attitude isn't everything but attitude
is the main thing that'll make a
difference in your life
because I believe that I wrote the book
the difference-maker
you see that's what attitude is attitude
is the difference maker you have two
people side by side that you're thinking
about employing in your company both of
them have the same background same job
description education experience I mean
you could almost flip a coin in second
hire the wet one on the right or I could
hire the one on the left but one has a
great attitude and one has a bad
attitude now who you gonna hire you're
gonna hire the person with a great
attitude why because it was the
difference maker so I always get
sceptical when anybody says that
something is everything right and I get
that people use it to make a point right
attitude is everything your ability to
sell is everything your passion is
everything your ability to make a
product is everything right everything
is everything
and so the goal then is just really for
me to be able to listen to different
bits of advice and take what we're
to me right your goal isn't to be John
Maxwell it's not to be Evan Carmichael
it's not to be Steve Jobs or Howard
Schultz it's to be the best version of
you and you can pull different concepts
from different people and try it out in
your life and see does it help you does
it make a difference the top ten rules
videos that I put out
maybe not all ten rules apply to you but
if one thing applies to you and that
makes a difference for you then that's
amazing you've learned something from it
you know I learned from a lot of
different people it's why I made the top
ten series and I'm introduced constantly
the people who have never heard of
before and it's really refreshing and
enlightening to bring in kind of new
blood and new ideas there's some people
who I have a lot of respect for and I've
learned some really important lessons
from and I put some of them on the wall
and and you may hate some of them like
you may hate Steve Jobs you may hate
Howard Schultz you may hate APO Giannini
hopefully you don't hate my parents you
know probably don't know my parents I
hope you don't hate them if you do it's
kind of hard to hate them with you if
you know my parents and that's okay but
even if you hate Steve Jobs you can
still learn something from him you can
still learn something Howard Schultz
even behaved him and you hate Starbucks
you can learn from all these people and
anybody who says this is the only thing
and I try not to do that maybe maybe I
do I don't know I try not to but maybe
I'm getting all excited I'll say
something like that just to make a point
don't take everything as absolutes like
it's it's so shocking to me what some of
the people in the comments find out
about a video like the point one little
thing out that I don't like in a video
like that that's what you took that's
what you learn from this video is that
this one person that one thing that you
don't agree with and so like everything
that they say is irrelevant to you if
you shut yourself off from learning
you'll shut yourself off from becoming
that best version of you and I think for
for me that's my goal and hopefully
that's the goal for you too
so the question bait today is I'm
curious to find out what have you
learned from different people what have
you learned from me or John Maxwell or
some people we talked about or somebody
totally different three things three
things that you've learned from three
different people super curious to find
out leave it in the comments below I
will join in the discussion I also
wanted to give a quick shout out to
Norway Jun I hope I pronounced that
properly I feel like I didn't thank you
so much for order
my boat means a lot to me and for those
you're watching for your chance at a
shadow in a future video make sure to
pick up a copy of the book and email in
your receipts so you can enter in the
draw thank you guys so much for watching
have an amazing day continue to believe
or whatever your one word is and they'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso